[Música]
alguna vez pensaron en innovar mientras
se tomaron los mates
soy marcos es touring y les voy a contar
mi historia
hace tres años estaba estudiando un
cuatrimestre de ingeniero industrial en
españa gracias a un intercambio de esta
casa
y todavía recuerdo el día que se ve por
primera vez me mate
tuve la suerte de compartir cursos con
chicos de todo el mundo que en ese
momento se abalanzaron para preguntarme
de qué se trataba que era cómo
funcionaba qué efecto de generaba
excepto por víctor
un amigo de berlín tiene ese momento me
enfrenta se enfrenta y me dice marcos en
alemania amamos la yerba mate
la verdad que en ese momento no le creí
y mi hijo si si amamos la yerba mate
pero no la tomamos de la forma
tradicional
sí no
que la tomamos en un formato de gaseosa
y una gaseosa con sabor a yerba mate
azucarada en una botella descartable la
verdad no lo podía creer y de repente
empecé a pensar un poco que en la
simplicidad
del mate cotidiano de todos los días se
escondía un producto con atributos
increíbles un producto 100% natural
estimulante un producto que no necesita
ningún tipo de envase entonces me
pregunté por qué será que mi amigo
víctor no toma mate si en cuanto a la
salud del medio ambiente estamos
hablando de que el mate es superadora
estás a estos productos porque será que
si las figuras más influyentes del mundo
lo hacen porque el mate no logra
globalizarse lo primero que hice para
responderme a esa pregunta fue
imaginarme a mi amigo víctor sentado en
un café de verdín con su computadora
llevándose unos mates y no fue muy
difícil darme cuenta de que era hacer
nada fácil para él llevarlo
correctamente saber todos los trucos de
la montañita un montón de cuestiones
culturales que nosotros ya lo tenemos
incorporadas como hacía yo para
explicarle que los primeros mates le
iban a resultar demasiado amargos pero
luego sigo acostumbrar como hacía yo
para explicarle
que si se revolcaba el mate río del
poder no iba a tener más chance de
aprobar el examen ahí es donde me doy
cuenta de que tenía un desafío por
resolver yo quería que víctor pueda
disfrutar del mate tal y cual como es
pero en un formato
familiar o conocido por él es decir yo
quería llegar a este punto verde que
viene en pantalla
ahí comienza
proceso creativo me llamo yo que me
llevo cuatro meses
un camino la verdad que es bastante
solitario y bastante frustrante de ratos
porque cada cruz que ven en pantalla es
un intento mío
de llegar a esa experiencia de llegar a
ese punto verde
y la verdad es que en un momento pensé
que nunca iba a llegar
hasta que un día me di cuenta de que el
error que estaba cometiendo era que no
estaba abriendo me y compartiendo mi
idea por ese miedo a que me la copien a
que me copien la idea ahora ya aprendí
que las ideas por sí solas no valen nada
y que no hay nada más valioso que
abrirse y compartir para retroalimentar
esa idea con distintos puntos de vista
porque al final siempre la persona que
menos esperas es la persona que te
sorprende y te ayuda a resolver esa
encrucijada y así fue
que luego de una larga jornada de
búsqueda creativa me recuerdo un viernes
de 8 de la mañana a 5 de la tarde
abriendo cajones buscando inspiración en
objetos cotidianos buscando distintos
objetos en el internet también siendo
pasear a la perra para ver si me
encontraba con algo
decidió cortar totalmente
frustrado
y me crucé en frente al salar con un
amigo y a contar de lo que me estaba
pasando
nos relajamos un poco empezamos a ping
pong
y de repente vi un globo arriba de la
mesa y automáticamente me doy cuenta que
ese globo reúne todas las condiciones
físicas para llegar al punto verde mi
amigo en ese momento mi hijo estás
completamente loco amigo
pero bueno yo sabía que se agarraba ese
globo y lo llenaba al conserva y le
metía la bombilla y los echaba con fuego
y después le hacía 40 edificios con un
alfiler
iba a poder sumergir ese dispositivo en
un recipiente con agua y cuando yo
succionase el agua del recipiente iba a
entrar por los orificios a la hierba y
luego a mi boca
y cuando yo no succionase el lobo se va
a cerrar
había descubierto la forma de tomar mate
sin necesidad de saberse bardo
había encontrado la forma de que víctor
pueda disfrutar del mate el tema es que
claramente nuevamente armat en globo así
que el siguiente paso fue
pues norma desarrollar un filtro que
emule este efecto
a través de microperforaciones y así
nace un sistema de consumo de infusiones
que se aplica el café se aplica al mate
se aplica el té que hoy en día está
patentado globalmente
para esta altura del viaje ya me había
dado cuenta que solo y encerrado
no iba a lograr ser tan rápido a este
objetivo de llevar el mate al mundo este
propósito de que gente como víctor pueda
disfrutar de los atributos de las
bondades del mate
así que
decidí formar equipo en primer medida me
puse a analizar
cuál era el alcance
y las
capacidades las habilidades los
conocimientos que necesitaba para
avanzar lo más rápido posible y por otro
lado me puse un poco en crisis a mí
mismo en cuanto a cuáles eran mis
fortalezas cuáles eran mis debilidades y
así fue que sume a un compañero de la
facultad con un perfil muchísimo más
duro y a un amigo de la vida con un
perfil creativo y especialista en diseño
y en desarrollo de marcas
juntos nos
pusimos como prioridad construir
prototipos eso que ven en pantalla
bajo la consigna de lograrlo lo más
barato y rápido posible
la verdad que en ese momento me daba un
poco de vergüenza
pero ahora los miro y sonrío cada vez
que los veo fuimos a una ferretería
compramos tubos de 13 años mechas barras
de polipropileno un montón de palabras
que no eran para nada familiar
nos encerramos en un taller y no salimos
hasta sacar los 10 prototipos fueron más
de 24 horas de construir algo sin tener
mucha idea y luego de eso nos propusimos
testear estos prototipos
con alguien como víctor pero bueno no
nos íbamos a ir hasta acá berlín así que
decidimos irnos hasta buenos aires
reservar un lugar tomar un evento con
extranjeros que no tengan ni la más
mínima idea o prácticamente no sepan
mucho de esta cuestión cultural del del
mate
y así fue que llegamos a obras aires y
teníamos el día previo al evento una
chica de australia y una chica de
alemania confirmadas pero claramente no
había mucho quórum para los 10
prototipos que habíamos hecho así que
entramos a desesperarnos un poco
y de repente se me ocurre google watch
youtube en buenos aires- tonight como
que qué hacer en buenos aires esta noche
y salimos a cazar extranjero salió vas a
pitchear en pleno palermo este proyecto
esta idea este esta forma de ver
este propósito perdón
y la verdad que cautiva mos la atención
de mucha gente pero solo
uno se animó a aparecer al día siguiente
y esa persona es verdad de canadá
qué pasas a nuestro nuevo víctor
el junto con las chicas nos brindaron un
montón de percepciones de sensaciones de
opiniones que a nosotros como materia de
sangre jamás se nos hubiesen ocurrido y
así fue que cerramos este producto
mínimo viable que rápidamente un fichero
se mostraba víctor por videollamada
víctor acá está la botella que vamos a
poder utilizar para disfrutar energía
natural del mate
tener conocimiento de nada agua hierba y
listo
y él me dice si está todo muy bien pero
yo la verdad que no voy a andar con una
botella para solo tomar mate para todos
lados claro en ese momento entró un frío
como pensé hay que arrancarlo de vuelta
pero no lo que hicimos fue desarrollar
un filtro para que él también pueda
tomar té para que él también pueda tomar
agua para que él también pueda cumplir
con otros antojos que se le presentaban
en la rutina
así que volvimos adictos amigo ahora si
tienes la botella para tomar mate para
tomar té puede tomar agua acá tenés
para que te des el banano sobre el
paquete de yerba no había ningún lado me
puede parar la policía como le explicó
lo que es aparte no tenía acostumbrado a
manipular la hierba
es un enchastre todo cosas que nosotros
como material nunca se no hubiese
ocurrido de alguna manera él como que
nos iba tirando esto esto va balde el
agua fría pero que iban refinando la
experiencia
y así fue que nace el concepto de
cápsula no lejos de querer parecernos a
las
exitosísimas pero tan contaminantes
cápsulas de café y queriendo conservar
la compostabilidad que como el atributo
más lindo que tiene el mate tradicional
decidimos compactar la hierba en
briquetas ser orgánica en briquetas le
sumamos extractos naturales para
acompañar las distintas etapas de la
rutina de
de víctor y bueno teníamos el producto
prácticamente cerrado
y de repente sentimos que estábamos
perdiendo como algo clave del mate que
es el tema del compartir este tema de
compartir la ronda compartir el mate que
de repente en contextos pandémicos ya no
se comparte más la bombilla pero si el
momento así que si decidimos sumar el
compartir como uno de los valores
fundamentales de nuestra marca en el
proceso de creación de la marca
principalmente porque queríamos que
víctor que verdad que las chicas
entiendan de que el mate no es un mero
energizante natural sino que es mucho
más que eso
y así fue que con la marca creada con el
producto cerrado
decidimos ir a buscar capital porque
claramente nosotros capital para encarar
el alcance este proyecto no lo teníamos
y había que convencer
jurados certámenes y eso también fue un
camino muy duro porque la verdad es que
no es nada fácil pinchar un proyecto así
principalmente porque tampoco tenía
muchas aptitudes comunicacionales y ya
es tuve que ir desarrollando y tuve que
darme la contra varios jurados hasta que
por suerte
llegamos a uruguay que nos abrió sus
puertas y nos dio
a través de un programa la posibilidad
de financiar
esta idea esta idea que una vez que se
suman mis socios se transforma en un
proyecto
y que ahora con este financiamiento se
transforma en una empresa
y que a partir de esta oportunidad nos
permite protegernos intelectualmente a
nivel global y nos permite hacer un
desarrollo en china
y nos permite conformar un equipo de
trabajo remoto contra pandemia desde
eeuu en argentina desde uruguay desde
austria y finalmente nos posibilita la
chance de lanzar de una manera global
de acuerdo a este propósito de llevar el
mate al mundo
a partir de una campaña de
financiamiento colectivo en una
plataforma
norteamericana
reunimos
900 órdenes a 49 países en 49 países ahí
está nuestra cara de felicidad después
de
la tortura que fue eso no le puedo
explicar que nunca haber enviado ni un
sobre a laguna paiva a tener que enviar
novecientas órdenes a 49 países la
verdad estamos muy felices de que se
vayan las las cajas pero finalmente
llegamos logramos
y mi amigo víctor finalmente se oye un
fanático del mate
de alguna manera
podemos decir que nosotros llevamos el
mate al mundo y vos hasta dónde está
dispuesto a llegar con todo lo que te
rodea gracias
[Música]